so uh what are the three things that are
certain in
life in
2024 well at least we know two of them
right death and taxes so these two are
Universal they never change but what is
the third
thing AI
SC yeah you have ai correct well I would
say the third thing in 2024 will be AI
is actually changing
Humanity so last year I saw this article
that some law firms are using G AI to
drave legal documents and some startup
even try to use AI to help clients argue
in court as opposed to using a human
attorney
so here I think it's important to Define
what we mean by Ai and I want to uh use
uh Mark redo's definition AI uh in the
context of this talk refers to
algorithms that perform tasks or
behaviors that person would reasonably
deem to require intelligence of human to
do
so uh of course U AI is too much
umbrella term and in this talk I
sometimes use it to refer to
non-traditionally AI things but for the
sake of uh Simplicity and consistency
I'm just going to use AI throughout the
talk to refer to a bunch of uh these
kinds of
algorithms so despite the promises of AI
I think there has always been a gap
between what AI can do and how AI can
serve
Humanity in the '90s uh Rich karan's
research project found that doctors
actually prefer rule based models
over better performing
neuronet does anybody want to know
why yes I guess there's something to do
with explainability like with the rule
base you can see how the decision was
made whereas the neuronet you might not
be able to figure that out precisely
that was the case so rule based models
allow the doctor to see the list of
rules AI used to make a diagnosis or to
predict the risk of pneumonia as opposed
to to Neon that function as a black box
that doesn't allow any changes or any
correction of AI
mistakes again was this paper
published uh it's uh I think it's the '
90s but the day was uh cut off in this
image yeah you can search for the title
it's it's published in kdd if I remember
correctly well this paper I actually I
was wrong this paper was probably
published much later but the project I
men mention was in the '90s so this
particular paper is I think it's in the
2000 all right so how do we close this
Gap I Believe by conducting human Center
design we can close this Gap to some
extent for example in this project I
work with my students and pathologist to
consider how we can use AI to help them
examine hisop pathology
images and there is no shortage of AI
models for pathology these days just to
give you some ideas here are a bunch of
uh existing startups working in this
space however there is currently a lack
of consensus about the adoption of AI
among pathologist because AI as of now
is still not good enough to completely
replace humans so it's really
unclear then how AI could fit into a
human pathologist
workflow to tackle this problem problem
we conducted human Center design few
studies with pathologies from bucl
Health our key finding was that
Pathologists could work with AI just
like how they work with the Tren KNE in
the way that they can see ai's findings
as if AI as a traine reporting back to
them and they serve as the expert
following a top- down workflow to verify
these AI findings
so here's the use interface we design
based on these
insights a pathologist would start by
seeing the ai's result here it shows is
wh gray three
tumor and then there will see at the top
level a number of criteria based on
which the AI model comes up with these
diagnosis and it shows that mitosis is
the top uh most important criteria in
this case
and then they can drill down to one
level deeper to see a list of evidences
based on which AI uh identify mitotic
cells as well as the cency map to show
that AI is indeed focusing on the cell
but not some other non-relevant
information so if they are still unsure
they can pick some of these sample
evidences and then drill down to the
original slide with full Contex
of the image to verify that AI is indeed
making the right decision on this
particular part of the image and along
the way if they see any mistakes they
can override those uh decisions and the
entire uh diagnosis if necessary will be
updated in a study with 12 pathologies
from three medical centers within less
than an hour of training they could
achieve more accurate grading using this
tool called cross path compared to an
existing digital
tool I think this project I just show
you is an example of how human Center
design can close the gap between what
pathology AI can do and how this kind of
AI can actually help pathologies
work so generally speaking my research
goal is to develop interactive systems
that can catalyze AI advances by working
towards fre level
of human Center
objectives augmenting human
abilities assimilating human intents and
uh aligning with human
values so next I would uh give you some
examples uh for one of these each of
these three
levels for augmenting human abilities
which is actually the majority of my
work in the past five years I have
explored the space of medical diagnosis
and research mechanical and robotic
design and uh text
reading so to give you an example I want
to focus on the second area mechanical
and robotic
design so in this project uh which is
the actually the my the last project of
my PhD so if people ask me uh when did
you change research from fabrication to
AI so this is the kind of the the point
where I realize H there is something
that it's really interesting uh it's so
it's called generative design even
though we're not really using G AI in
particular so the goal in this project
was uh we want to augment human's
abilities to design both structure and
appearance structure and appearance are
both important but they often trade off
each other in the traditional mechanical
design tasks existing tools often
prioritize structural
Integrity but they lack the
interactiveness for users explore uh
with within the goal of structureal
Integrity how can I explore
appearances to understand this tool
called Forte Let's uh work through the
process of using it to design a lag for
a quadropad
robot to start the user would perform
some simple
sketches and describe the loading
scenario so here's the original uh
robotic lack we want to
redesign and user can just sketch some
shapes like this curvy uh structure they
want to create this uh the robotic lag
off and then they will also specify the
load which is the weight of the robot's
body onto this leg as well as the Bing
condition which is where uh this this
robot lag makes contact with the world
on the ground as well as the design
domain you can think of it as a b uh as
Bing box that uh covers the space in
which uh this lag can take
place after these simple sketches and
annotations next the user can use Forte
to generate structures based on the
sketch for example uh the user can ask
the tool to add additional support
because the initial sketch might not be
sturdy enough to support the weight so
here uh Forte as a parallel structure
next to the users original
sketch all the user can ask the tool to
create a variation based on the original
sketch so here it looks a little bit
different but still uh the resulting
structures try to stay similar to the
original
sketch and the last technique is to
consider the the
sketch as defining a boundary within
which uh the optimization can put in
more structures to provide
support you can think of these three uh
techniques as incorporating the
appearance information the sketch into
the optimization by trying to mimic the
users sketch in the Genera process of
the
structures importantly we need to allow
users to control this
generation so we provide This Global
similarity slider by increasing the
similarity value uh AI would try to stay
as close as possible to the original
sketch versus a lower value would allow
AI to go a little Wilder to generate
structure that look more
different you can see the differences
between two similarities
and then once the user sees a result
coming back they should be able to think
about it and make some edits and then AI
should take into consideration in the
next uh iteration so inter uh allow the
user to perform this direct addit onto
the ai's result by erasing certain parts
of the
structure which then prompts the AI to
consider the those erasion uh in the
next iteration and the user can keep
doing this back and forth until they are
happy with the
result or they can add more structure if
they see this is probably too empty and
they want to add a trust and then the
optimization process would try to
incorporate that kind of
intents in the next
iteration and importantly we need to
inform the user along the way what's the
trade-off because not all kinds of
structure would have the same type of
structural Integrity so we provide this
visualization view a heat map that
visualizes the the stress distributed
over the
structure and lastly we can go into the
fabrication
process uh in this case we use a laser
cutter and install the new legs on the
quadropad robot
all right so that is a process of
Designing the leg as an example of using
this tool so what's happening under the
hood is this algorithm called topology
optimization that is based on a well
defined well established method finite
element
analysis the basic idea is that the
process of generating a mechanical
structure is given a design domain you
need to decide within this bounding box
which El elements I want to keep and
which I want to throw away uh you can
think of it as like sculpting right you
have a bunch of material and then you to
C away the those you don't want and then
whatever is left is what you want to
create so we have a design domain in
this case Tod of these finite elements
uh XE and then this entire domain of
elements will undergo the optimization
process where each iteration tries to
either increase or decrease each
element's dens
governed by this objective function
until eventually the compliance uh
converges uh with minimum compliance
means that with maximum structural
Integrity given the limitation of the
material as well as the user sketch to
follow so this fem uh method is already
uh out there and we didn't change it at
all we use it as a black box but the the
way we enable these novel interactions
is to tweak whatever comes out of this
SP boox in each iteration so in each
duration uh this black box would split
out for each element a new
value and I'm going to go through some
of the the approaches that enable the
three techniques so for adding a new
structure we simply say whatever is on
the user sketch we keep it anything else
we follow what objective function
sets for obtaining a variation instead
of manipulating this uh XE new we
instead distribute initial value when we
assign uh the mass the material to the
design domain we say the closer the
space is to the original sketch the more
initial material we assign that kind of
steer the optimization process towards
preferring uh being closer to the users
original sketch determined by the
similarity
value and for the last technique
optimize within we simply say uh we
going to expand user sketch and then
whatever is on the boundary we keep it
whatever's outside of it don't do
anything and whatever inside follow the
optimization
function okay the other interesting
thing I I think about this tool is how
the user can directly added the ai's
result so how do you do that uh remember
we have this design domain that AI work
with so we also create a mask of the
equal Dimension that represent the
users's addit so for each element on
this mask we be set it to one by default
between zero and one if it's erasing and
a value greater than one if it's adding
new structures and at each iteration we
simply apply this Mass uh to the ai's
output at that
iteration so at the high level you can
think of as steering the optimization
towards resemblance of the users add
itss quick question yes why are you
doing it as a multiplication here as
opposed to just building it into the
optimization CR function itself or the
the loss function yeah the the other
approach is to do what you said but that
involve changing the FM method which we
try to avoid in the first place and in
this way you can also think of it as
trying to counterbalance two objectives
back and forth until eventually it
converges we haven't tried the
approaches that it could generate
equally good or even better
result all
right so we ran user study and here are
the results created by the participants
so I think the Highlight here is that by
using this Tool uh according to the
results here as well as parti
participants feedbacks they were able to
explore the kind of appearances that
were not possible because other tools
didn't address both structureal
integrity and appearance so when using
other tools you're mostly concerned
about uh the structures but Forte allows
them to kind of balance these two
considerations using
AI after publishing this paper we also
open source it and then we let some CMU
designer use it to create furniture so
if you ever visit CMU maybe in new
assignment Hall you would see this
furniture now has been I know six seven
years maybe
not we didn't use very good
material and it's also available uh
Forte on GitHub I tried to update it
periodically but unfortunately I didn't
have time recently the last update was
in 2021 if you're interested feel free
to uh download a source code and then
play with
it so Forte takes a human Center
approach while conventional optimization
is often entirely driven by an objective
function Forte augments user ability to
design both appearance and structure by
sketching annotating and direct editing
of ai's results
so I think this direct adding editing of
AI results is the most important and
interesting feature because it finds a
way to assimilate uh users editing
intents directly into the optimization
process even without modifying the
objective function per se so next I want
to talk a little more about this problem
of assimilating uses
intents and I want to switch gear a
little bit to talk about um image
generation so we know human intents
could be either explicit or
implicit for example a lot of the gender
AI these days only takes into explicit
intents mostly as a Tex
pump but some intents are actually
implicit that is they are not fully
expressed usually or naturally in
explicit forms for example if I
asked uh stable diffusion to generate a
surprise pH you can say yeah surprise is
an explicit intents but uh what kind of
surprise facial feature I want is
unclear whether what they are because I
might have some ideas in my mind but
they remain implicit they are not
specified in this tax prompt and I
probably wouldn't want to specify to
that kind of
details so the question we're interested
at is how we can elicit users implicit
intense without the effort or the
unnatural process of specifying them in
a Tex
prompt when we work on this problem uh
we were not exactly deing with like
diffusion models or the latest models
we're still working with generative
adversary networks or game so for those
who are less familiar so again is was a
thing before the diffusion models took
over so it was able to generate contents
from points or noises in the latent
space so each point l space represents
for example an image and if you think of
it that way then a vector that connects
two points can be consider an editing of
this one image to become another called
an editing Direction such as making the
phase appear to be older
aging so the question is um how can they
user discover amongst this large latent
space which editing directions would
generate images that match the
intents so when we started look into
this question uh we found that in the
literature uh there is something called
information foraging Theory that's
surprisingly relevant so it was a pretty
old uh piece of work uh it was the this
particular technique that embodies this
Theory called scatter together was
published in 92 C the main idea is that
when you are confronted with a large
collection of documents you can
first uh cluster them into a bunch of uh
create a bunch of clusters and they
select some clusters that seem
interesting to you and then you scatter
them into new clusters and then you
repeat this process so you'll see more
and more five grand clusters until
eventually all these clusters seem very
interesting all together to
you so we felt this would be appropriate
to help us tackle this intent Discovery
uh for G editing
directions and we develop this tool
called gzilla so here the user would
start by seeing an initial set of
clusters so remember here each thumbnail
is not just an image it actually
represents a set editing directions that
change the original image to the Target
image to the end
image so the user might say hm these two
sets of adding Direction seem
interesting to me because I see what's
uh inside these two clusters on the
right side and then I can scatter them
into new a new set of clusters to see
more F in a more F Grant manner uh how
these two clusters addit the faces and
then I can repeat this process over and
over until eventually um I can select
the type of editing that really closely
match my
intents so here's how it works uh in
motion the user can also change the
number of
clusters or to get more images if they
are not happy with the current
batch and then they say they select
these two clusters that interest them
the most and then they would scatter
these into a new set of clusters very
similar to the technique we just saw in
the 92 paper they can also go back to a
previous
cluster and they can keep doing this
iteratively and they can also test this
adding Direction on other images to see
how they
generalize and change the the strength
of applying the editing
Direction and save these uh edits for
future
uses so how well does it work uh we
conducted some evaluations so here's the
close-ended tasks we gave participants
some reference images and asked them so
here are the target images try to use
this tool to find the editing direction
that changed the reference image the
target image and the middle Bunch uh
were the participants work
using gzilla you can see they could uh
find a match amongst the many editing
directions to move the image from the
reference more much closer to the Target
images so we also conducted some
quantitative
analysis by comparing the similarities
we found that the similarity between the
user generate image and the target image
is indeed greater than similarity
between the rest reference and the
target image meaning that they will what
they create what they have found out
using Godzilla is closer indeed closer
to the Target image compared to
reference
images the second task we did was
running some uh multi 36 round
comparisons in each round we compare
with 1,000 randomly sampled adding
directions from the latent space and
amongst these 36 round 33 times we found
that the user generated images rank in
the top five in similarity to the Target
images we also conducted an open-ended
task so here the user the participant
were asked to make the face in the
reference image more followed by a
descriptive
keyword so each row uh represents a
descriptive keyword so by looking at
these results could you you guess which
three keywords we gave the
participants each row is a different
keyword looks like the t is more
difficult in the reverse
way I'm guessing the top row is like
more thrilled or something like that
more thrilled okay
yes L surprised
yes the one's probably the mo most
obvious all right so uh the first row is
actually Older second happier and the
last row more
surprised all right so to to verify that
they indeed uh succeeded in some uh to
some degree we ran some quantitive test
we found that uh in terms of uh making
the phas older age increases by 10 years
and we we did all this analysis using
tools from this paper and when it comes
to happy uh the confidence level
increases by 45% and then surprise
increased by
56.7% this proved that they were indeed
moving along uh this intent of making
them the spaces older happier and most
and some other tasks uh including
include using clip embeddings to compare
the similarity between these descriptive
keywords as well as the user generate
images so in particular We compare the
these similarities uh between the users
work and the top 10 amongst 1,000
randomly generated sampled
edits and then we found that user gener
images are more similar to the free text
keywords compared to just uh randomly
finding directions from the lat
space so some of you might be uh asking
hm G is so yesterday why don't we just
use text to image
models well I would say it's still not
outdated this approach because gzilla
our tool assimilates uses implic intense
beyond what text proms are capable
of and why is that because with text
proms it's hard to describe the exact
faal features of old happy and surprise
that you have in
mind you have to look at the results and
then maybe tweak The Prompt and then try
a bunch of results again until you
happen to see one that matches what you
have in mind but gzilla allows users to
discover what match the intents using
the scatter GA
techniques so some of you might notice a
tiny detail in this figure I used a few
slides
ago uh it shows that uh
besides the being implicit the actually
more challenges in handling human
intents so for example uh as of November
last year when I asked uh mid journey to
give a successful tech company CEO often
times it will return predominantly male
images so why is that is actually
technically a problem called
entanglement is because the attributes
of CEO and male are entangled for some
reasons in the generative process that's
why uh these models are always
generating male CEO images even though
it didn't specify that in your
prompt so entanglement uh just shows
that there is another problem in using
AI it causes AI generation to misalign
with human values because I don't
believe any of us believe that human uh
CEO should be male so how do we design
uh ways for users to combat this problem
of
misalignment so the next uh project
precisely tackles this issue yes use um
en theat space of these images um the
lat space is usually very unstructured
sometimes did you consider something
like yeah we did not but that's a good
idea we probably should have uh try
other ways as well but we primarily
focus on taking the G structure as is
and then construct use interface to
interact with
it so this next next project is also
based on game
model uh of course there are existing
approaches to uh combat entanglement
issues most of them are algorithm driven
for example interface Gan requires uh
developers to predefine this
entanglement rules for each domain and
then human annotators to label large
data sets so these are a great ideas and
they work but I argue that there are
still problems of these sorts of
algorithm driven value alignment
approaches first it's not possible to
predefine universally agreed upon value
for example what bias
means and secondly even if you already
have an algorithm driven
disentanglement approach working you
cannot guarantee that when it's shipped
to the end usance the model will always
generate bias free images or other
contents which means that we need to
somehow provide the the last line of
defense for the users to combat entangle
bias
generation so in this project we work on
a user driven Direction disentanglement
approach for
gain so uh here's the initial images you
can see some clear entanglement
issues uh when adding glasses through
these faces for some reasons uh the
generative process is in Tangled with
gender
and age old so for some reason has some
assumptions that uh people who wear
glasses often male and old
people okay so at an end user when you
see these results on the UI uh what can
you do so we came up with this
idea uh called Global disentanglement by
n users so the end user would sample a
bunch of positive which means with
glasses and negative means means uh
without glasses
examples and as they sample these
examples they can intentionally select
those that are different that uh counter
the entanglement issues like female with
glasses young people with glasses and
give these count examples more
weights so in this process by providing
the
examples uh this tool is able to to
overcome some of these entanglement
issues so the results have improved as
you can see that now uh the gender
entanglement is gone but the age
entanglement is still
there and then the users just continue
to add more images uh to compat the age
disentanglement so here's the before and
the after
comparisons so besides Global you can
probably imagine there are some local
things uh to do for this entanglement so
indeed the user can say um I want to add
glasses so areas around the eyes are
okay you can make changes but you
shouldn't change the background so these
two types of masks kind of provide users
additional constraints uh specified to
the model
yeah so just a comparison of the three
kinds of results before Global after
global and after global plus local
entanglement okay so how does it work
under the hood so for Global
disentanglement we can visualize the
problem as so here's the gray error is
an adding Direction so it's supposed to
be parel to glasses but for some reason
is in in between o and glasses so you
want to kind of rotate this this acting
Direction More align or more parallel
with glasses so the way we do that is by
using the user selected example weighted
examples to calculate this Vector added
to the original adding Direction uh to
make it less entangled uh this this blue
Vector was calculated from the users
selected weighted
examples
and for the local disentanglement we
look at the Futures in the game model so
remember the two masks so one is here is
okay to make changes here is not okay to
make changes so we're intersecting with
the Futures so these two masks either
strengthen certain edits or weaken
certain edits to avoid uh the local
disentangle to avoid local
entanglement all right so here are the
results but by participants in our study
we can see that using this tool they can
deal with entanglement on their own
without going through the algorithm
driven retraining annotation
process and compared with some existing
algorithm driven approaches you can see
the quality of this entanglement from
our participants are comparable
sometimes even better which is
encouraging because it tells us that uh
the value alignment problem is not just
about AI models it can also be addressed
on the user interface
level okay so uh so far I've talked
about three example
projects co-designing both structure and
appearance as a way to augment human's
ability to do mechanical design by
interactive
sketching and discovering implicit
intense based on information foraging
Theory and then allowing users to
disentangle biased image generation on
the
UI so this space of human- centered uh
interactive AI systems is still pretty
nent to me at least the the last two uh
space intents and values and I believe
there is a lot of opportunities for
future work so in interest time I just
want to briefly touch on some of the
directions I'm thinking about in the
future to see if uh some of you might
have uh common ideas or Inspirations we
can discuss
about so first for augmenting human
abilities I believe one of the the
important missions for Humanity is to
support scientific
discovery so despite the tremendous
progress we have seen the past 100 years
or so surprisingly there is very little
changes in certain scientific discovery
process so here's kind of a joke SLS
serious example I asked CH gbt to
describe in picture what it's like for a
scientist to work on drug Discovery
between 1923 and
so other than even the same actor
probably not much has changed right the
tubes the lab the the
equipment but Jokes Aside uh that's
actually the case there's really not
much significant changes in the drug
Discovery process which I think is still
pretty
suboptimal is time and cost consuming
new drugs to the market usually cost a
billion dollar over 14 years and that's
only guarantee 10% success rate and
involves lots of man work in an
iterative multiphase process so even
though we HDR people are good with
iteration but their iteration is really
painful they would start with 100 Cas of
compounds in the first phase to narrow
down to hundreds of hits and the second
phase to tens of leads and then the last
phase to narrow down to one or two
developmental candidates assuming that
the previous phases are
successful so the question here is uh
given some existing AI development that
try to help this process how can we
design uh novel tools and systems to
catalyze this kind of AI to actually
help accelerate the drug Discovery
process so the topic about uh
assimilating human intents I'm thinking
about is AI with a theory of
mind so a theory of mind is this idea
that we humans have have some ways of
inferring each other's mental States so
the figure here is the classic false
belief test so the mom ask the child uh
what do you think is in the Box the Box
labels as Smarties but when the child
opens the box it actually pencils so now
someone else enters the room the mom ask
the child so what does that person think
is in the
box so a child with who has developed a
theory of mind would think about this
problem for from that person's
perspective who doesn't have his own
knowledge about the Box actually
contains contents other than the smarts
so this ability to think in other
person's shoes is called theory of
mind so why do we care about this
because uh surprisingly or not
surprisingly AI these days is quite
opposite it knows very little about the
very human that is interacting with it
just to give you an example so here's
what chat gbt actually currently sees as
a
human really not nothing but a tax
prompt right he has no idea who you are
what you are
doing or what's going on in your mind it
is nothing but a text
box so the question here is how to
catalyze this kind of AI with thear of
mind to infer a human's unspoken intents
and with that kind of new knowledge
allow AI to be more
helpful and the last Direction I'm
thinking about is using AI to mediate
human
communication uh in support of value
alignment uh we have established that
there's really no universally agreed
upon values so that's why I think it's
important uh to enable better
communication existing Technologies
often make communication more convenient
but that doesn't necessarily mean um it
would make humans better communicators
every time we communicate right we have
generated thoughts in our brain
translate them into speech uh outter the
speech which is heard by the other
person and then go the reverse way of
becoming thoughts and in their brain so
this is very complicated and lengthy
pathway a lot of things could go wrong a
lot of things could be improved given
the advances of AI to give an example so
my student Bruce work on this project
called visual captions so trying to to
make our Zoom conversation more lively
by automatically adding visuals so let's
take a look at his demo implemented
visual captions as a user customizable
Chrome extension for video conferencing
platforms to use visual captions users
simply speak as they normally do for
example if you're visiting Los Angeles
you should definitely check out the
Disney land and the Universal Studio
visual captions will automatically
captures the user speech and suggest
visuals in the private scrolling
view I actually just went to Disneyland
with my family last
weekend look it was such a fun time
users May click on a suggested visual to
show it
publicly inspired by our formative study
visual captions additionally provides an
autod display mode in this mode the
system autonomously searches and
displays visuals for users and in on
demand mode where users need to tap the
space bar to explicitly request a visual
suggestion we evaluated visual captions
with 26 participants in total
participants found visual captions
helped them explain and understand
unfamiliar Concepts make information
more intuitive clarify language
ambiguities and make conversations more
fun
and okay so even though it's not
directly dealing with value alignment I
hope these kind of uh systems would
Inspire similar work to think about how
we can support humans to better
communicate share values and more also
importantly I would like to explore how
AI instead of remaining on the sideline
in this project could take an even more
uh aggressive or proactive role how can
AI directly participate in human
communication not just as an observer
and someone who suggests what to show
but as something some someone that's
that's really similar to a human uh
Communicator in this
process all right to summarize um we
have uh talked about the three things
are certain in life in 2024 and Beyond
we are sure that AI is and will be
changing
Humanity despite his promises of AI we
also know there's
and has always been and always will be a
gap between what AI can do and how AI
can serve
humanity and to close this Gap I believe
we should be uh building interactive
systems that catalyze AI to achieve
these three levels of uh human Center
objectives augmenting human values
assimilating human intents and aligning
with human values so with that I want to
conclude the talk and happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
all right we have some time for
discussion hello thank you for being
here I was mostly curious about the
user's role in the user
disentanglement um one question I had is
there any reasonable way to measure the
amount of disentanglement that needs to
happen because to your point there are
no Universal values um so perhaps it's
always iterating and we're always
looking for different people with
different values to kind of provide
input or any thoughts on that yeah
that's a very good point so is there any
way to measure
uh the amount of uh disentanglement
needed on that user interface or the
amount of effort uh needed from the user
so the short answer is that we did not
provide that kind of support but it did
come to us as an afterthought so how
would users actually tackle this
entanglement issues how many samples
they select how many ways they will
assign to different samples I think
future world should develop some sort of
uh uh data logging to observe this kind
of us behavior and better understand how
they use this
tool yes see how like AI can easily
manipulate a face into different facial
expressions um kind of got me thinking
about like in the airport um we got like
I don't know if you see there's like a
line called clear my parents like got it
so we could just go fast it's kind of
scary because you don't even need to
scan your boarding pass it just looks at
your eyes
and then it already knows who it is out
of their database of thousands millions
of people how would you say that like we
can balance ethics with like having a
database that can recognize people just
solely on their
eyes yeah that's very big
question how do balance ethics and
ability well I think there's a lot that
could be done in the life cycle of
developing these kind of AI models from
responsibility collecting training data
to verifying the models such as it
shouldn't uh only recognize certain
people because they dominate the
training data through the design of user
interface to inform user any uh ethic
related behavior of this model uh for
example the there could be some sort of
model C us interace to let the user know
some very brief description about how
this model Works what data is based on
what sorts of uh uh problematic Behavior
currently exists so that the user of
this system uh can understand that the
extent of this models ability and
limitations so I think there a lot of
work on throughout this entire process
of developing and using
facial recognition
AI
yes at the end you mention like for the
F work want more proactive
system but begin beginning you also
mention like people sometimes don't have
enough charge to this kind of system and
they want to have like more control and
rather than directly receive the model
output so how can we balance like this
kind of thing and how more Pro yeah so
in the visual caption project we already
developed uh the the solution to your
question is we let the user select three
ways of AI proactiveness so AI could
either
uh suggest visuals on demand so user
have to press a button or AI would
suggest uh visuals
automatically so you see a suggestion
but nothing would happen Happ you have
to approve or AI can add visuals
automatically so you trust it that you
can allow AI to add visuals without you
doing anything so having these different
levels of proactiveness for the users to
choose from is our current
approach yes thank you so much for the
talk um I just wanted to ask a question
regarding like augmenting human
abilities yes um so like with like um
having someone sketch out like a robotic
leg versus like having some machine just
um like automatically like make like a
lot of robotic legs um so what's the
advantage of like having this like human
input and augmenting it as opposed to
like just having it all like
automatic I would say the major benefit
is that you can allow the user to
express their own creativity so not
everyone has to order from the same
manufacturer to buy robotic leg each of
us can create their own design while
this tool help them ensure that their
creation uh has sufficient structural
Integrity I'm curious about some of
these techniques you're using to guide
like danilla and so on um it seems like
one of
the
we're often in HCI kind of routing
around the algorithm outputs like we we
sort of take the pre-trained Gan and
then we're trying to elicit the um the
dimensions inside of it that might be
semantically meaningful and so on we're
sort of we're taking its output and then
we're trying to kind of work around it
it seems like if it were possible to
directly train these things with some
notion of say human
similarity you could give people much
more powerful levers over this and you
what we were at some level what we're
missing is the the the the model on The
Human Side like a cognitive model or
something like that but that that that
would act in the same way as your mask
did to sort of be a joint optimization
mhm I'm curious if you see any
opportunities there or do you think it's
going to sort of remain
hard my understanding is that way you
refer to is the more Al algorithmically
driven approach where your developer
have to uh specify what is entanglement
they have to collect additional data
label this data and then use those to
disentangle the model or they could have
to Trend recognition model to say well
this is getting older this is getting
more surprised and us that kind of
additional models to enable semantic
control so if that's what you mean then
yeah indeed that that already happening
in the AI Community there's been a bunch
of work uh using this kind of approach
and uh our work is almost complimentary
to what they do so instead of um working
with the model directly we try to allow
at the user interface level at the last
L of Defense once the model has been
fixed by developers but it might still
be problematic or you might still
struggle to find what you want what else
can we do at the user interface level
and how much do you think that that user
interface winds up being co-designed
with the algorithm anyway like if you
swapped out say again gzilla or Gans for
auto encoders or stable diffusion or
anything else how much do you feel like
you would like let's let's set aside the
algorithm behind it but how much would
the interface have to change yeah
integrate are they uh I would say
is semi Loosely integrated so for both G
Zilla and G reel uh the only thing
that's coupled with G is this notion of
Ting Direction MH that means uh you
would start from some sort of latent
representation of the image or whatever
you want to create and then you would
manipulate it through the network as
long as you have this notion of editing
Direction then the user interface
doesn't have to change a lot so we
actually change a bit from gz to G rvel
instead of just working with vanilla
again we're actually working with Style
again so it's not exactly the the the
initial latent Vector it's actually the
style Vector it's different but is the
same concept so that somehow shows we
have some sort of generalizability
Beyond being coupled with just a static
model
yeah I have a question um in your your
vision what would be the main user of
Zealand because I'm thinking in
society who is interested on this
entangling the data sets and so do mean
uh the last project can re this
entanglement yes yeah yeah if you care
about the quality of uh image generation
so whatever you use image generation for
it could be making a thumbnail of your
YouTube video creating a company logo if
you care about quality then entanglement
is a almost Universal problem and then
those people can use this interface to
improve the quality of the outcome of
the AI
models all right then let's take our
speaker